alright guys so you know I'm a huge fan
of the original Avengers film I love
that movie I thought it was the perfect
mishmash of fun superhero comic
adventure but also some really good
depth in there and just a really good
understanding of the characters in
general and so naturally I am very
excited for the Avengers age of Ultron
or Avengers 2 now a teaser premiered at
Comic Con which has recently leaked this
footage doesn't have any actual footage
from the film because it hasn't started
filming yet it does however have a sort
of interesting image of Ultron's head I
can't show you the footage because it's
official what I can do is provide a
download link in the description below
for those who would like to see it who
are angry that I'm not showing it to
them right now who thought that they
were going to the trailer but they're
actually seeing some guy talking I
apologize if you don't know who I am
thanks for watching but to you guys who
are awesome and you watch me all the
time I am extremely excited for this
movie for obvious reasons although this
teaser trailer doesn't really show any
new footage it got me pumped here in
that crowd screamed and you can't
duplicate that you know that's something
that only exists in this this realm of
fandom these people that get so
incredibly excited for these movies I'm
really interested to see where this film
goes because Ultron isn't a villain that
everyone loves
but Whedon has said that he's gonna take
it in his own direction which I
appreciate because the guy at this point
has proven that he understands geeky
comic fandom in the description below I
have left a download link for this
leaked trailer as I said there isn't any
new footage
except for this interesting look at
Ultron's head I'm pumped out of my mind
for the Avengers 2 I'm hoping that at
some point we get some leaked actual
footage which would be pretty awesome
but for the most part I'm really just
excited to see that first official image
of some of these heroes together I can't
wait to see that and even this footage
that is mostly images and dialogue still
got me extremely excited for the movie
and I can't wait to see it here's a
stupid question for you are you guys
excited for Avengers 2 guys as always
thanks very much for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes